[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans Sciences publiques votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportage et d'analyse sur Public Sénat
bonsoir et merci pour votre fidélité
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à
nous suivre tous les jours du lundi au
jeudi à 18h et 22h voici le sommaire de
ce 26 janvier le chômage continue de
baisser en France 114000 personnes ont
retrouvé à un emploi stable au quatrième
trimestre 2022 cela fait plus de deux
ans que la tendance se confirme comment
expliquer ces chiffres alors que la
crise frappe de plein fouet les
entreprises le plein emploi est-il un
objectif atteignable d'ici à la fin du
quinquennat l'année 2023 peut-être celle
de la récession en France réponse de nos
experts dans une minute et puis cette
question pour notre second débat débat
de société jusqu'où les robots et
l'intelligence artificielle vont-ils
nous remplacer
c'est une technologie horizontale de la
médecine au divertissement de
l'agriculture à l'industrie la
logistique les analyses prédictives les
langues cela permet d'innover dans la
technologie pour sauver des vies et
rendre la vie meilleure les choses nul
l'intelligence artificielle va-t-elle
améliorer nos vies ou rendre obsolète
des valeurs comme le travail et le
savoir l'apparition de chat GPT ce robot
conversationnel capable d'écrire des
dissertations des recettes de cuisine ou
le mode d'emploi pour fabriquer des
armes à relancer les interrogations sur
l'IA il faut apprendre à vivre avec vous
verrez mais d'abord donc cette bonne
nouvelle sur le front de l'emploi en
détail les chiffres du quatrième
trimestre 2022 avec Flora sauvage la
baisse du nombre de chômeurs semble se
poursuivre selon les chiffres de Pôle
Emploi diffusés hier le nombre de
chômeurs sans aucune activité a connu
une aide diminution au quatrième
trimestre 2022 pour s'établir un taux de
chômage de 7,3% de la population active
une bonne nouvelle pour le gouvernement
qui a comme objectif d'atteindre le
plein emploi d'ici à 2027 avec un taux
de chômage à environ 5% mais
l'opposition sénatoriale reste qui
regrette on a à la fois un contexte
économique national internationale qui
est favorable quand même un certain
nombre de difficultés il faut quand même
conscient que le poids de la dette que
l'évolution technique son intérêt on a
quand même des indicateurs qui sont
inquiétants malgré une conjoncture
incertaine des effectifs des demandeurs
d'emploi de catégorie a continué de
baisser ce qui n'est pas le cas des
chômeurs de catégories B et C qui ont
une activité réduite un effet de vaste
communicants que d'État et cette
sénatrice socialiste on constate que le
nombre de chômeurs catégorie A c'est à
dire ce qui ne travaille pas du tout
baisse mais que les autres statistiques
et qui concernent les gens qui
travaillent un peu
augmente ça veut dire que plus de gens
reviennent dans l'emploi mais peut-être
de manière un peu précaire voilà un
bémol qui n'empêche pas le gouvernement
de mettre en avant des signes positifs
sur le marché du travail comme la
réduction du nombre de chômeurs de moins
de 25 ans et de plus de 50 ans alors
même que l'emploi des seniors est l'un
des enjeux de la réforme des retraites
je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de notre premier débat Olivier
Babeau bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
professeur université de Bordeaux auteur
de ce livre la tyrannie du
divertissement qui est apparaître la
semaine prochaine de février aux
éditions Buchet Chastel Stéphane carcio
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
responsable de la division emploi et
revenu de l'OCDE professeur associé à
Sciences Po Pablo Pillot Vivien bonsoir
Pablo bonsoir merci d'être là et
bienvenue rédacteur en chef de la revue
regard Émilie zappalski bonsoir Émilie
spécialiste en communication politique
et éditorialiste pour sciences publiques
pendant cette émission merci à vous
aussi et bienvenue je rappelle c'est ces
chiffres du chômage catégorie à une
baisse de 3,6% au quatrième trimestre
2022 ça représente 114000 demandeurs
d'emploi en moins au plus bas depuis
2011 et plus de deux ans de baisse
constante du chômage tiens je commence
avec vous Stéphane quercieux est-ce que
c'est un succès pour le gouvernement
est-ce qu'il faut reconnaître ça ou que
c'est plus compliqué
c'est un peu plus compliqué parce que
cette baisse du chômage elle est un peu
multifactorielle
il y a clairement une tendance je dirais
qui est commune à d'autres pays
européens de baisse tendance du chômage
et d'augmentation de l'emploi
en sortie de crise du covid pourquoi
parce qu'il y a un effet de conjoncture
qu'on a qu'on partage avec nos voisins
beaucoup d'entreprises ont été très
protégées en Europe des effets du de la
crise du covid ont su beaucoup de
subsides et en même temps on gelé tous
les projets de recrutement et puis tout
le monde finalement c'est à réouvert au
même moment avec créant de fortes
tensions sur le marché de l'emploi et et
finalement reprenant la baisse son
ancienne qu'on avait connu du chômage
avant la crise du covid donc cette le
marché du travail a été mis en pause
d'un seul coup tout le monde se réveille
avec des projets qui se remettent en
marche au même moment et entreprise et
salarié d'ailleurs et donc ça crée un
grand mouvement de réallocation d'emploi
et de baisse du chômage parce qu'on a
une
en CDI pour les employeurs et ça on l'a
vu dans les recrutements CDI aussi ça
c'était les faits des ordonnances il y a
eu les réformes de l'assurance chômage
et de limiter l'intermittance
notamment l'assurance chômage il y aura
vraiment un chapitre consacré à ça dans
l'émission Olivier Babou est-ce qu'il
faut est-ce qu'ils sont surprenants
d'une certaine façon c'est ces chiffres
ils sont ils sont un petit peu ils sont
aussi surprenants peut-être que la la
relative bonne santé des marchés
financiers en ce moment compte tenu des
perspectives de 2023 qui n'ont a priori
rien de très très encourageant c'est une
croissance dont tout le monde s'accorde
qu'elle va ralentir au niveau mondial
qu'elle va être très faible en France
peut-être entre 0 et 1% 300 fortes
croissance faible évidemment c'est moins
d'activité n'est-ce pas on a aussi des
chiffres d'inflation dont on n'est pas
tout à fait sûr qu'on soit au pic on
peut l'espérer mais on n'est pas certain
il y a un stabilité géopolitique sur
lesquelles il y a pas le début d'une
solution malheureusement dans le conflit
ukrainien et on sait absolument pas où
ça mène il y a de l'argent dans ton C
qui va continuer à devenir beaucoup plus
cher c'est à dire que la politique des
banques centrales va continuer à
augmenter les taux resserrer le crédit
ça fait moins d'argent donc
théoriquement moins de facilité à se
financer tout ça ça devrait rendre les
patrons frileux
mais en effet il y a il y a d'autres
effets qui qui ont joué c'est à dire que
pendant le covid on a quand même déversé
250 milliards d'aide aujourd'hui avec
l'inflation on avait reversé 48
milliards en 2022 on prévoit on va
verser à peu près 58 si je me trompe pas
en 2023 donc une aide donc ça peut
maintient des entreprises à flot quoi ça
peut maintenir alors la question c'est
ce qu'on a des entreprises et donc des
emplois zombies on a vu en tout cas que
beaucoup une baisse de du nombre de de
de de fermeture d'entreprise de faillite
est-ce que ça veut dire que le jour où
on coupera le robinet ce qui est pas été
le cas encore hein on n'a pas ruiné le
couper le robinet des aides du tout le
jour où on le coupera est-ce que on aura
en face de nous une sorte de rebond
extrêmement fort c'est pas impossible on
peut le craindre en tout cas ce qui est
vrai c'est quand on interroge des
entreprises quand on en rencontre
aujourd'hui on est beaucoup plus face à
une guerre des talents face à une
pénurie d'emplois dans beaucoup d'autant
plus qui sont qualifiés d'ailleurs et ce
qui d'ailleurs aurait pour conséquence
théoriquement économiquement de
d'augmenter de faire une pression à la
hausse sur les salaires Pablo Pillot
Vivien quand on voit ses chiffres on
devrait tout simplement se réjouir sans
se poser de questions ça fait deux ans
que ça baisse sauf que ben il y a
toujours un mec oui il y a toujours un
mail d'abord parce que moi et je ne suis
pas le seul j'ai toujours considéré que
cette indicateur en fait des chômeurs
catégoria qui baissent ou qui montent
étaient absolument terrible et ne disait
pas grand chose finalement de la réalité
de la vie des gens de la réalité de leur
rapport au travail je rappelle que
aujourd'hui là quand on regarde
d'ailleurs c'est dans c'est dans les
c'est dans l'étude aussi qui est sorti
sur le dernier trimestre de 2022 vous
avez 10% des une augmentation pardon de
10% des radiations administratives des
chômeurs donc c'est une façon aussi de
faire baisser en partie et d'obtenir le
chiffre dont on parle aujourd'hui et
puis il y a des catégories B et c'est
pardon nous interrompre on voit que ça
augmente donc là c'est des gens
travaillaient qu'on travaillait quelques
quelques heures ou quelques dizaines de
les chiffres et je vous laisse la parole
plus 5,2 % catégorie B + 2,3% catégorie
c'est exactement du coup si on prend les
catégories ab et c ça fait seulement une
baisse de moins de 1% d'accord ça c'est
la première chose et surtout ça ne dit
rien en fait de la qualité des emplois
que les gens ont finalement trouvé parce
que évidemment si vous affamez les gens
si les gens n'ont plus rien pour vivre
non plus rien pour pouvoir se nourrir ou
se loger ils vont prendre n'importe qui
n'importe quel type de boulot et vous
avez des gens par exemple qui sont des
bacs + 3 ou des bacs plus 5 et qui vont
pour des raisons qui sont qui sont
propres à la alors survie en fait vont
accepter des boulots qui vont pas être
qui pensent être argument Pablo mais il
est contradictoire avec ce que tu viens
de me dire Olivier Babou sur un marché
de l'emploi qui est en train de se
retourner donc plus plus les plus niveau
d'études est élevé plus on est en
capacité enfin c'est ce que j'ai compris
en capacité de finalement négocier un
emploi qui qui nous convient bah
attendez allez voir sur le marché de
l'emploi moi j'aimerais bien honnêtement
j'ai cherché avant de venir dans cette
émission j'ai cherché en fait des
données sur
l'acceptation en fait par les en parler
les les futurs empl par les salariés
d'un boulot je ne les ai pas trouvés ils
n'existent pas il y a des vieilles
données en fait qui datent de 2010 et
qui montre mais du coup le marché de
l'emploi à l'époque n'était pas du tout
le même et qui montre que ben en fait
les gens acceptent à peu près tout et
n'importe quoi on pense logique et
effectivement changer un énorme problème
et ce qui est ce qui est renforcé
aujourd'hui bar
ce qu'on parle du marché de l'emploi
mais on peut aussi parler du problème de
de comment on récupère cette sociale on
parlera tout à l'heure de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage en fait qui
paupérise toute une partie de la
population de gens qui n'arrivent pas à
retrouver un emploi on peut parler aussi
du chômage des seniors des plus de 50
des plus de 50 ans qui effectivement le
taux d'emploi chez eux ça augmente parce
que ça pour le coup je trouve que c'est
un indicateur plus intéressant le tout
d'emploi aujourd'hui en France on est en
dessous de 70% de taux d'emploi j'ai
regardé en 2019 on était à 67 % de taux
d'emploi peut-être que ça a évolué
depuis vous vous prenez par exemple
l'Allemagne ils ont un taux d'emploi qui
est plus pour les 15 65 ans pour les 15
65 ans l'Allemagne on est à 10 points de
plus
moi je pense qu'il y a quand même un
rapport de force qui est en train de
changer parce qu'on voit déjà en effet
qui accepte des postes un peu n'importe
quoi qui acceptent aussi pas n'importe
quelle condition et surtout qui change
c'est à dire qu'il n'hésite pas à
accepter une offre et à bouger par la
suite parce que ils ont des conditions
meilleures par ailleurs on sent que ça
bouge énormément mais là où moi je
mettrai un bémol par rapport à la crise
covid et ce qui a été fait c'est qu'il y
a beaucoup de défaillances d'entreprises
qui reprennent alors on n'est pas au
rythme d'avant la crise covid de faire
une entreprise
d'augmentation en 2022 c'est des signaux
quand même qui montrent qu'en effet on
va être au poste quoi qu'il en coûte et
que ça peut être dommageable et il y a
des secteurs particulièrement impactés
qui sont le commerce la restauration et
souvent c'est des artisans et on le voit
là les boulangers avec les factures
énergétiques ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il y a une différence entre les
grandes entreprises qui globalement vont
suivre ces rythmes d'embauche et de taux
de chômage assez réduit mais à l'inverse
les artisans et les petites PME là pour
le coup je crois que le paysage n'est
pas du tout le même panorama n'est pas
du tout il y a une vraie question vous
avez commencé à l'aborder c'est la
question de la qualité de ses emplois
bon très bien alors moi je vais vous
donner un chiffre qui contredit plutôt
ce que vous nous disiez Pablo Pio Vivien
c'est alors c'est le ministre du Travail
qui donne
proportion record de CDI nous dit
Olivier du subs 52 % des embauches en
CDI donc là moi j'en déduis que la
précarisation de l'emploi est plutôt en
train de se réduire en français est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ça moi je
pense qu'il est un peu trop tôt pour
pour vraiment
dire que la précarisation de l'emploi se
réduit l'objectif des réformes ces
dernières cette dernière décennie en
tous les cas a été de réduire la ce
dualisme du marché du travail entre d'un
côté des emplois très précaires très
courts des CDD très courts et de l'autre
côté des emplois très protégés on voit
une tendance sur le CDI c'est vrai
mais progression des progression décédée
on la voit depuis quelques années depuis
trois quatre ans et c'est plutôt très
encourageant
mais on revient de loin quelque part
parce que c'est vrai que la part des des
personnes qui sont en CDD à quasiment
doublé en 20 30 ans donc on a quand même
énormément de marges de manœuvre pour
revenir un peu dans les clous cela est
temps c'est vrai qu'on voit une
amélioration et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que vous venez de dire
c'est ce qu'on voit dans les données
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a de telles
tensions sur le marché du travail que le
rapport de force pour une grande
majorité peut-être pas pour tous mais
pour une grande majorité de de personnes
notamment de jeunes qui ont un peu de
diplôme ceux qui n'ont pas de diplôme ne
sont pas dans ce rapport de force mais
les autres changent parce qu'en fait les
tensions sont très très fortes et c'est
surtout très très fortes à cause de ces
phénomènes de conjoncture et de
rattrapage des entreprises qui cherchent
à tout prix à lancer leurs projets
qu'elles ont mis en suspent pendant deux
ans et et aussi parce que elles adoptent
de nouvelles technologies
et qu'elles ont besoin de de nouvelles
compétences donc un rapport de force qui
est en train de changer clairement en ce
moment il recruter et fidéliser
les les salariés les collaborateurs
c'est vraiment un enjeu majeur dans les
entreprises aujourd'hui
très souvent moi l'entreprise pour faire
des conférences aujourd'hui il y a une
seule chose qui obsède les entreprises
alors c'est vrai plutôt des grandes
entreprises évidemment c'est pas des TPE
ou des PME qui ont des moyens
puis qu'on doivent fonctionner ils
doivent embaucher beaucoup de gens c'est
la marque employeur leur problème c'est
la marque empire c'est-à-dire le limaces
de l'entreprise vis-à-vis des je sais en
fait la vraie question c'est comment on
attire des jeunes puis comment on les
garde parce qu'il voit arriver des
jeunes qui restent quelques jours
quelques semaines et puis qui s'en vont
et c'est vrai que c'est une attitude qui
nous doit du monde d'avant on est tous
très jeunes ici mais enfin du monde
d'avance c'est un truc qui était pas
imaginable je veux dire moi j'ai grandi
dans un monde où il y a 3 millions de
chômeurs il y avait plus de 10% actives
donc si vous aviez un emploi c'était le
Graal c'était formidable fallait garder
il fallait et aujourd'hui on a
l'impression qu'il y a une sorte de on
est beaucoup de décomplexé et donc en
effet le rapport de force d'une certaine
façon échanger mais attention c'est un
dualisme aussi parce que si vous êtes
formé évidemment alors si vous êtes
spécialiste en LLM parler de chat gipity
LLM c'est les
largement les les modèles qui permettent
d'entraîner en fait tchat GPT
spécialiste de ça artificielle vous
commencez à quand vous avez un million
si vous le savoir donc vous êtes
spécialiste de ça c'est formidable
[Musique]
si vous avez effectivement la compétence
qui est hyper rare aujourd'hui
franchement les grandes entreprises
elles s'arrachent dans l'assurance dans
la banque aujourd'hui il y a aucun
problème vous pouvez vous la chaîne il y
a le bout de la chaîne les les nouveaux
le premier Taria qui qui nous livre
quand on a la flemme d'aller faire nos
courses avec un paradoxe parce que c'est
ça la réalité hôtellerie café
restauration on manque de gens sauf que
le modèle économique à valeur ajoutée
relativement faible c'est que c'est très
difficile de proposer l'augmentation de
salaire qui permettrait de rendre moins
rare les demandes enfin les les gens qui
veulent travailler et donc
malheureusement le vrai dualisme
aujourd'hui dans le monde du travail
aujourd'hui et ça va s'accentuer à mon
avis c'est cette différence croissante
entre des emplois très qualifiés très
très fortement rémunéré pour certains et
une masse d'emploi dont la demande est
très forte parce que beaucoup de gens
ont les moyens de se payer ses services
et dont les conditions de travail sont
souvent pas bonnes et en tous les cas on
a du mal à les améliorer et et je crois
que le vrai dualisme je suis tracé ce
qu'on appelle la polarisation du marché
du travail on observe dans dans
quasiment tous les pays de l'OCDE et on
observe aussi en France c'est deux
pointes là beaucoup d'emplois très
qualifiés on n'arrive même pas à fournir
tellement il y a de demandes sur les sur
les ingénieurs et beaucoup de demandes
aussi sur les emplois peu qualifiés avec
des conditions de travail qui pour le
coup sont avec la parole à Pablo pardon
Emilie mais avec un défi évidemment pour
les secteurs là on parlait il y a il y a
je crois que c'était il y a deux jours
sur ce plateau de des Jeux Olympiques
Paris 2024 et les enjeux en matière de
sécurité le nombre de de personnels pour
les entreprises privées c'est c'est en
dizaines de milliers que ça se ça se
compte bon bah ces métiers là il y a
beaucoup de gens qui n'en veulent plus
qu'ils pratiquaient et qui tout
simplement n'en veulent plus dans les
conditions actuelles Pablo piwiya moi ce
qui m'intéresse aussi je voudrais que on
fasse un focus un peu sur l'emploi des
jeunes parce que vous l'avez évoqué
est-ce que si on essaye de faire la part
des choses entre les grandes tendances
et puisqu'on peut mettre au crédit du
gouvernement est-ce que par exemple les
les réformes l'apprentissage vous nous
dites là quand même ça ne fonctionnait
pas bien il y a eu une réforme ça va
mieux oui non mais c'est vrai
honnêtement l'apprentissage par rapport
à encore une fois il y a un côté
rattrapage enfin je veux dire
l'apprentissage dans les années dans les
années 90 c'était déjà un sujet en fait
sur lequel on se disait il va falloir
faire quelque chose parce que dans la
situation actuelle c'est absolument
catastrophique donc en fait au fur et à
mesure des différents septénats puis
quinquennat on est arrivé à quelque
chose qui pour moi est loin aujourd'hui
d'être d'être tout à fait correct mais
enfin effectivement il y a des avancées
du côté des jeunes effectivement moi je
comprends en fait ce dont vous parlez
mais le problème enfin comme ça a été
dit par Olivier Babeau c'est en fait
quel métier de quel métier on parle on
sort du covidence on sort du covid quand
même où ont été mis en avant les métiers
de ce qu'on a appelé la première ligne
les métiers qui étaient vraiment ultra
nécessaires à la à la survie économique
de notre pays à la survie tout court de
nos des Français et des Françaises ces
était là je suis désolé de le dire mais
on y arrive toujours pas le compte n'est
toujours pas bon ni pour les nids du
côté du des personnels soignants on a
toujours besoin d'infirmiers on nous dit
oui on va embaucher 3000 alors c'est
vraiment c'est le bout du monde en
embaucher 3000 alors qu'à a priori les
demandes c'est plutôt entre 30 et 50000
infirmiers et infirmières dont on aurait
besoin aujourd'hui c'est la même chose
pour les médecins c'est la même chose
pour les caissiers les caissières enfin
je veux dire en fait tous ces tous ces
métiers là donc c'est super en fait
qu'il y ait plein de gens pour faire des
chats j'ai pété ou j'ai pas quoi genre
non mais c'est notre second débat donc
vous pourrez vous inquiétez pas on aura
vraiment le temps d'en parler en fait
ces métiers parce que vous dites métiers
ultra spécialisé mais faut voir ultra
spécialisé dans quoi c'est à dire que
moi aujourd'hui je vois je l'ai très
souvent sur Pôle emploi et en fait il y
a beaucoup beaucoup de d'emplois on dit
bon bah voilà vous serez community
manager et c'est quoi votre formation va
voir une formation de community manager
alors c'est important d'être community
manager je ne dis pas le contraire et
c'est un métier qui est aussi noble
qu'un autre mais enfin je suis désolé
mais si on commence ici tout le monde
commence à faire des diplômes du
community manager parce qu'il y a des
sites absolument partout dans tous les
sens
il y a un problème en fait dans ce que
dans la direction en fait qui est en
train de prendre notre pays on a aussi
besoin de nos industries on a aussi
besoin de pouvoir manger on a aussi
besoin de métier on est aussi besoin de
l'enseigner une exception sur
l'industrie parce que l'industrie a du
mal à recruter pourtant ils sont en
pénurie de main d'oeuvre il y a beaucoup
d'emplois qui sont disponibles et là
pour le coup c'est des emplois qui
peuvent être peu qualifiés au départ et
qui progresse au fur et à mesure
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut avoir des
fonctions de plus en plus importantes et
là on a du mal c'est en terme d'image je
pense que c'est l'attractivité qui est
complètement déficiente le gouvernement
essaie d'attirer d'attirer des femmes
d'attirer des hommes sur ces métiers là
mais on a beaucoup de mal et c'est
pourtant un ascenseur social qui est
très efficace dans l'industrie et en
plus c'est une période pile-poil comme
il faut puisqu'on veut réindustrer des
affrances réé localiser des activités
industrielles mais après la crise covid
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on vit
quand même une double transformation la
transformation numérique qui avait
commencé il y a quelques années et la
transformation écologique ou
environnementale Olivier Babeau donc ça
ça provoque quoi ça provoque des
mutations dans les dans les métiers et
parfois des décalages entre les
formations et les besoins des
entreprises et peut-être même aussi le
degré de connaissance des candidats de
dans ces nouveaux métiers c'est ce qui
crée ce qu'on appelle théoriquement le
chômage structurel c'est à dire c'est un
problème d'appariement vous avez pas les
compétences en face des besoins un
moment donné et on est dans une économie
où les besoins évoluent de plus en plus
vite les compétences
deviennent obsolètes pardon de plus en
plus rapidement et donc les formations
du mal à suivre on voit à l'université
vous rendez compte vous formez des gens
ils vont travailler dans une économie
dont vous ne savez pas vraiment à quoi
elle va ressembler puisque dans 10 ans
personne ne sait exactement ce qui va
ressembler donc à quoi à quoi elle
ressemblait qu'elles sont les
compétences donc d'ailleurs vous essayez
plutôt de les former à apprendre à être
extrêmement large mais la bonne nouvelle
sur les chiffres de l'emploi montre que
paradoxalement là on aurait pu dire que
la difficulté d'appariement était de
plus en plus grande on arrive à avoir
une difficulté finalement qui se réduit
plutôt on a un chômage structural qui
était à 8% on a l'impression qu'on est
peut-être entre 5 et 7 on va voir disons
qu'on est en train de tester le bas et
c'est plutôt heureux c'est plutôt une
bonne surprise en fait c'est à dire que
on a un système de formation qui
évidemment pas parfait on n'a pas
toujours les formations en face mais ça
s'améliore quand même ce qui veut pas
dire qu'il y a pas des problèmes très
graves d'être activité et à tous les
métiers qu'on a cité j'aimerais ajouter
celui d'enseignants dans primaire et
dans le secondaire le fait qu'il est
plus il est moins de candidats que de
poste offerts au concours c'est un truc
qui est sidérant et extrêmement
inquiétant pour l'avenir une condition
de travail ça a l'air derrière les
questions effectivement quelle
restauration c'est les horaires
l'agriculture oui mais il y a un point
qui me semble important pour relier un
peu les questions de qualité de l'emploi
et de et de de l'enseignement justement
c'est
effectivement quelle économie on veut
demain quel type d'emploi on veut demain
et je pense que pour pour ça le le le
les politiques décidées par le par le
par le gouvernement ont parlé
gouvernement général ou un rôle
important
l'investissement dans la recherche le
développement
dans l'université et l'enseignement
c'est évidemment hyper important
pourquoi parce que lorsque les
entreprises que dans un pays il y a
énormément d'ingénieurs et que il y a
beaucoup de pôles de recherche etc elles
ont tendance à venir s'installer et à
développer des ce type d'activité
quelque part voilà la demande des
entreprises sur le marché du travail va
aussi répondre à l'offre donc mais
est-ce que tu pardon nous devons une
parenthèse est-ce que je vous laisserai
conclure après mais est-ce que la France
est plus attractive pour les grandes
entreprises étrangères aujourd'hui qui a
et on va dire cinq ans ou 10 ans alors
quand on regarde des enquêtes oui
clairement il y a une amélioration de
l'attractivité de la France
pour plusieurs raisons pour des raisons
réglementaires pour des raisons
d'infrastructures pour des raisons aussi
de développement de pôles d'excellence
ces dernières années voilà ça revient
dans le sud de la France dans la nord de
la France autour de Paris à saclette etc
ça ça a eu un rôle très important mais
cette cette dynamique là je pense qu'il
faut l'accélérer très clairement il faut
il faut il faut l'amplifier parce que
quelque part les emplois de demain
dépendent de ça les emplois dans 10 ans
et dans 20 ans dépendent de cette
dynamique là et en fait pas seulement
les emplois qualifiés pour reprendre une
idée
vous savez quand vous allez dans la
Silicone Valley la Silicone Valley et
l'endroit où probablement où on paye le
mieux les ingénieurs notamment les
ingénieurs en informatique évidemment
mais ce sait aussi l'endroit où on paye
le mieux les médecins les avocats mais
c'est aussi l'endroit où on paye le
mieux les restaurateurs les serveurs et
quelque part ce que je veux dire c'est
que la valeur ajoutée de ces secteurs en
pointe
oui mais pour le coup là elle ruisselle
un peu polémique mais c'est pas c'est
pas la valeur ajoutée c'est pas le
ruissellement des milliardaires c'est
pas du tout le sujet c'est le
ruissellement de ce de ce pôle de valeur
ajoutée qui est énorme et ses emplois
qui sont des emplois souvent de
l'industrie high-tech ou des nouvelles
technologies va ruisseler sur la qualité
des emplois qui sont autour et qui vous
savez aujourd'hui quand vous avez une
usine
l’intéressant d'avoir une industrie
aujourd'hui en France c'est pas
tellement enfin les emplois dans
l'industrie dans les usines c'est
important mais aujourd'hui les usines
qui vont revenir sur notre territoire
elles vont être essentiellement
automatisées et d'ailleurs les gens qui
vont venir travailler dans ces usines
seront des ouvriers très qualifiés parce
qu'il faut maîtriser les les les robots
et et les diriger mais ce qui compte
c'est pas tellement l'emploi de ces
usines c'est tous les services qui sont
autour c'est pour ça que c'est très très
important d'avoir aussi cette
infrastructure une manufactorielle et de
la conserver et de la maintenir et c'est
cette infrastructure magnifique elle va
venir aussi si elle est pôle de
recherche et de développement dans la
robotique dans la physique etc qui sont
là je reprends la main avec cette
question peut-on atteindre le plein
emploi en France ici à la fin du
quinquennat 2027 c'est évidemment un
objectif du gouvernement et pour
l'atteindre en tout cas c'est l'argument
qui est donné il y a cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage alors on va en
parler d'abord avec Mathias
bienvenue Mathias bonsoir à vous bonsoir
donc une réforme qui ont l'actualité de
ces derniers jours nous nous a presque
fait oublier que cette réforme existait
et oui une réforme peut faire de l'ombre
à une autre réforme apparemment si on
remonte un petit peu dans le temps 21
novembre 2022 le ministre du Travail
Olivier du subt présente le projet de
décret faire moduler les règles d'un
indemnisation selon la situation du
marché du travail si la conjoncture est
bonne entendait que le chômage est
inférieur à 9% la durée d'undemnisation
des chômeurs se réduit de mécanismes de
protection toutefois un minimum de 6
mois d'indemnisation garantie et un
complément de fin de droit si l'état du
marché s'est détérioré entre temps dans
le cas où la situation serait plus
tendue c'est à dire un chômage à plus de
9%, ou une augmentation de 0,8 points en
un trimestre la durée d'indemnisation
revient à la normale et donc c'est 7
versions du texte qui va rentrer en
vigueur là dans quelques jours le 1er
février oui avec effet immédiat le
chômage étant aux alentours de 7% les
bénéficiaires d'allocations verront la
durée de leur indemnisation baissée de
25% du au lendemain exemple concret je
suis demandeur d'emploi j'ai
actuellement 24 mois de droit et avec
les nouvelles règles et bien le premier
février je n'aurai plus que 18 mois
alors je vous demande si c'est cette
version du texte parce que le
gouvernement voulait aller plus loin
absolument c'était la surprise du chef
elle avait de Noël le gouvernement sans
en tenir informé les partenaires sociaux
à modifier sa copie un nouvel alinéa
prévoyait qu'en cas de situation
extrêmement favorable moins de 6% de
chômage la durée d'indemnisation aurait
été amputée de 40% des annonces qui ont
crispé les partenaires sociaux qui les
ont qui les ont même fait bondir
résultat le 3 janvier c'est la reculade
Elisabeth borne annonce le retrait de ce
point prétextant un manque de discussion
merci Mathias on va justement écouter
Elisabeth borne c'était sur France Info
on prévoit de passer une indemnisation
de 24 mois à 18 mois en effet
l'hypothèse on a voulu être transparent
en affichant toutes les toutes les
situations et les règles qui
s'appliqueraient y compris si le taux de
chômage ce qu'on souhaite évidemment
passe en dessous de 6%. moi j'entends
que ce point n'a peut-être pas
suffisamment fait l'objet de discussion
donc nous allons le retirer à cette
troisième ce troisième niveau du décret
qui entrera en vigueur au premier
février et nous remettrons ce sujet dans
la concertation sur les futurs règles de
l'assurance chômas qui revient avec vous
sur cette séquence cette annonce des
événements n'a pas tout pacifié entre le
gouvernement et les syndicats parce que
le mauvais cadeau de Noël il est pas
passé c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
ce projet décret donc il y a finalement
été supprimé par le gouvernement janvier
c'est passé c'est passé très mal c'est
un des syndicats comme l'a expliqué
matelas Mathias consiste à réduire de
40% la durée d'indemnisation des
chômeurs si dommage passer sous la barre
des 6%, ce qui en plus est peut-être pas
on va peut-être pas y arriver mais non
seulement les syndicats n'ont pas été
informés du dispositif mais en plus ils
ont été mis devant le fait accompli et
ils ont eu l'impression de revivre le
même scénario que lors de la précédente
réforme de l'assurance chômage en 2019
une sorte de retour vers le futur des
concertations autour de l'assurance
chômage on pourrait dire puisqu'en 2019
le gouvernement leur avait déjà tendu
une sorte de piège en leur demandant une
économie de 4 milliards d'euros à
réaliser et c'était mission impossible
devant l'impuissance des syndicats et du
patronat à se mettre d'accord sur cette
mission justement qui était impossible
l'État avait repris la main pour
dérouler ses propres règles en
suspendant un moment la réforme à cause
du covid mais en proposant serait propre
règle du coup lorsque le gouvernement a
dansé en octobre 2022 les concertations
les partenaires sociaux ils ont revécu
la même chose c'est-à-dire que
finalement ils ont compris que les
enjeux de la discussion étaient déjà
fermés les principes d'une modulation de
l'indemnisation des demandeurs d'emploi
en fonction de la conjoncture économique
c'était déjà le principe était déjà acté
finalement il n'avait la main que sur
les modalités pour faire cette réduction
d'indemnisation et ça leur a pas plu du
tout ils ont vraiment vu qu'ils vivaient
la même chose que en 2019 une feuille de
route trop contraignante qui les
empêchait de mettre leur grain de sel
là-dedans et même la CFDT pourtant le
syndicat le plus réformiste a été
complètement opposé à cette nouvelle
règle alors il faut dire que Laurent
Berger auparavant avant qu'Emmanuel
Macron arrive au gouvernement il était
plutôt habitué à donner le la des
discussions c'était plutôt lui qui
allait dans le sens où en tout cas qui a
amené le gouvernement vers des décisions
là le président Emmanuel Macron il fait
fit des corps intermédiaires il les
renvoie plutôt à leur rôle enfin en tout
cas à la place qu'il estime la leur
c'est-à-dire dans les entreprises pour
lui c'est le politique qui compte avant
tout c'est ce message qui est qui est
assez clair mais alors si en 2019 et
avec la crise covid la tempête c'était
un peu calmée puisque les formes avait
été suspendue et quand elle a été
reprise on n'avait calmé les esprits ces
dernières entourloupes autour de la rue
assurance de la de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage et surtout autour de
ce projet de décret et bien ça a été
comme les dernières gouttes d'eau qui
ont fait déborder le vase juste avant
l'annonce de la réforme des retraites la
mère des réformes donc ça a provoqué un
front syndical uni on le voit bien ce
qui s'est passé après la mobilisation ça
a contaminé l'opinion publique et de
plus en plus opposée à la réforme des
retraites on voit dans les derniers
sondages alors il faut voir si les
actions qui sont engagées ça est là pour
maintenir la pression sur le
gouvernement seront toujours du coup de
tous les syndicats parce que c'est vrai
qu'on entend parler d'opérations type
Robin des Bois on rend on donne des
tarifs réduits par exemple au boulanger
qui souffrent de leur facture
énergétique on réduit ou on rend
gratuite l'électricité pour les hôpitaux
pour les écoles pour les crèches mais
peut-être qu'au fil du temps ça risque
de déplaire à certains syndicats on sait
notamment que pas tellement la culture
de la CFDT effectivement merci Émilie
Pablo puis Olivia cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage on va essayer de la
décortiquer ensemble déjà politiquement
c'est intéressant parce qu'elle est
portée par deux personnalités venues de
la gauche ils avaient de bornes et
Olivier du soft mais si alors peut-être
de du peut-être du centre gauche est-ce
qu'elle est d'inspiration libérale pour
autant cette réforme elle est totalement
d'inspiration libérale enfin genre et
moi je vais vous dire et même elle est
même particulièrement cruelle d'ailleurs
au même titre que la que la réforme des
retraites et il y a un député
renaissance du Loiret qui a hier sur
France Bleu a mis les deux en parallèle
en fait moi honnêtement je je dire aux
gens et en plus j'ai entendu les
arguments de la de la de la team
renaissance de la team macroniste en
gros expliqué que mais vous comprenez il
y a des gens qui se gavent sur le
chômage qu'utilisent ça pour leur
période entre deux boulots pour prendre
des vacances etc mais en fait lorsque
j'entends ce type argument je me dis que
leur environnement à ces gens qui
défendent cette réforme de cette façon
là passer des gens qui doivent gagner
10000 balles par mois et donc du coup
quand un chômage qui est très important
parce que lorsque vous êtes au SMIC ou
lorsque vous êtes à peine au dessus du
SMIC et que vous êtes et que vous êtes
au chômage que vous êtes licencié et
genre votre chômage c'est peau de
chagrin c'est-à-dire que vous pouvez à
peine vivre avec votre chômage parfois
vous êtes en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté qui est aujourd'hui de 1100
euros en France donc pour ces gens là
pour ces gens là la réduction en fait de
l'indemnité et du temps pendant lequel
est alloué c'est un des meilleurs qui
m'intéresse la réduction du temps de de
l'indemnité parce que voilà est-ce que
ça peut peut-être être un levier
d'efficacité mais un lieu d'efficacité
pourquoi les gens non mais pour des gens
qui déjà vont avoir un chômage je sais
pas moi par exemple de 1000 euros par
mois et pendant ces gens vous croyez que
il donne pas tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour
essayer de trouver un travail il y a des
dizaines en fait de reportages dans les
médias notamment de seniors qui cherche
un boulot et qui disent mais vous faites
comme ça mais
ces gens là ils cherchent un travail je
fais comme ça parce que on est en même
temps dans une période où on l'a dit
dans le débat et on a expliqué pourquoi
mais il y a aussi tellement de de
recruteurs qui qui qui peine à trouver
des candidats donc bon et en fait au
bout d'un moment d'accord parce que
c'est pas bien payé ce qui est souvent
vrai parce que l'emploi n'a pas de sens
ce qui est souvent vrai aussi mais bon
voilà mais le problème moi en fait ce
que je dis c'est que on met dans une
situation de précarité extrême voir de
pauvreté extrême toute une partie de la
population qui cherche un travail qui on
ne peut pas dire en fait que ces gens ne
font rien que ces gens sont des
fainéants ou que sais-je peut-être que
ceux qui ont un chômage à je sais pas
combien de milliers d'euros eux et qui
sont et qui ont un décapitaux et je sais
pas quoi il y a un appartement payé
peut-être que pour eux effectivement
cette réforme alors
je voudrais je voudrais maintenant
donner la parole à nos deux autres
invités peut-être Olivier Babou pour
commencer est-ce que c'est on va je
rappelle le principal on réduit la durée
d'indemnisation quand le chômage baisse
et puis on en force quand il remonte
est-ce que on pourrait aussi se dire
c'est du bon sens qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez alors sur ce sujet qui
effectivement sujet difficile il faut
essayer de garder raison garder
le principe me paraît un principe
relativement simple bon il y a en effet
des situations qui sont hétérogènes
derrière le principe c'est vrai il y a
des gens qui par exemple pour les
seniors du fait d'une d'une culture qui
fait que à partir de 45 ans n'est-ce pas
45 ans on vous considère comme étant un
seigneur en entreprise qui vous prend
assez de formation c'est étonnant bien
sûr évidemment alors il faut garder de
la caricature de dire les chômeurs le
sont par choix c'est une peut-être une
infime minorité de gens qui le seraient
par choix en revanche ce qu'on sait
c'est que l'incitation aussi marche
qu'on continue à avoir le système le
plus généreux du monde vraiment c'est à
dire que le système continue mais après
la réforme va être parmi les plus
généreuses si ce n'est le plus généreux
en durée et en montant etc d'ailleurs je
crois bien qu'il y a pour les hautes
pensions enfin pour les hautes
indemnisations dans la réforme une
baisse une dégressivité qui est décidé
évidemment qui touche pas les plus
belles les plus basses pensions ce qui
est quand même une façon de mettre les
plus riches peut-être à contribution
peut-être ceux qui gagnent 10000 euros
et qui tout d'un coup sont évidemment au
chômage et en profite donc ce qu'on sait
aussi c'est que quand vous baissez la
durée de d'indemnisation Vous avez des
gens qui retrouvent plus facilement du
travail l'incitation marche quand même
un petit peu et c'est pas absurde le
principe paraît pas complètement stupide
de dire bon quand le marché du travail
est moins difficile les les règles vont
un petit peu changé quand il est plus
dur on vous protège beaucoup plus c'est
une façon d'essayer de ménager quand
même je trouve la chèvre et le chou
Stéphane carcio si on essaye de de
peut-être se poser sur la réalité du
marché de travail est-ce que
les chômeurs de longue durée retrouvent
forcément des emplois plus stables ou
mieux rémunérer vous voyez ce que je
veux dire est-ce que là la question
c'est est-ce qu'on a des mises 24 mois
ou bah depuis le premier fait 18 mois
seulement est-ce que est-ce que le fait
de d'être un chômeur dans longue durée
vous rapproche du plein d'un emploi
stable par exemple ou pas d'ailleurs là
il y a dans ce domaine je pense qu'il
faut vraiment ce qu'il faut regarder
c'est les études les études empiriques
sur le sur le sujet qui ont étudié le
comportement des demandeurs d'emploi en
fonction de la durée d'indemnisation
maximale
il y a plusieurs études qui ont été
réalisées concernant la France qui
parlait probablement les meilleurs
chercheurs au monde sur ce sujet parce
que la France est d'excellente données
et notamment il y a une étude de
Yona marinsko et Daniel scandalis qui
était se donner sur des sur les sur
environ 400 000 demandeurs d'emploi
suivi entre 2013 et 2017 je me souviens
bien donc c'est du sérieux c'est du tout
alors là vous nous faites le résultat
c'est du très très faible résultat et ce
qui est très intéressant dans cette
donnée c'est que que ce soit des
personnes qui avaient droit à 6 mois
d'indemnisation à 12 mois à 18 mois ou à
24 mois ces personnes se mettent à
chercher dans les deux mois qui
précèdent la fin de leur de leur
indemnisation c'est à dire qu'on c'est
ces deux chercheuses sont allés regarder
le nombre de candidatures sur le site de
Pôle emploi et elles ont vu une
multiplication juste avant et donc cette
multiplication elle se traduit par une
augmentation un saut soudain de la
transition vers l'emploi d'accord donc
les gens cherchent et ça paye et ça paye
particulièrement particulièrement
lorsque l'économie va bien donc
évidemment là ce que quand l'économie va
mal en covid vous postiez des des des CV
ça ne donnait rien en ce moment ça ça et
dans les juste avant justement la
période du covid l'économie mettait
quand même assez assez dynamique elle
est toute sortie était très importante
les gens qui vont chercher plus plutôt
donc ça veut dire que il s'agit pas de
dire c'est de la faute des chômeurs qui
sont qui sont des des fainéants qui
cherchent pas etc tout le genre tous les
gens réagissent de manière rationnelle
et demandeurs d'emploi aussi certains
probablement mettent alors que
l'économie va bien un peu plus de temps
que ce qu'il devrait pour chercher le
raccourcissement de 24 à 18 mois va
aller faire chercher plutôt et du coup
va les faire sortir du chômage plutôt et
a tendance lorsque amis va bien lorsque
l'économie va bien en moyenne et ça
aussi en moyenne à accélérer la sortie
du chômage maintenant il y a des
situations très hétérogènes et
évidemment ça donc en fait on donne la
parole
j'ai juste une question c'est une
personne qui a 6 mois de chômage est-ce
qu'elle a du coup elle a moins de temps
pour chercher un emploi est-ce qu'elle
trouve un emploi qui est moins ce
qu'elle voulait que une personne qui
aura 24 mois pour le trouver alors
cette question là c'est la question de
la qualité des emplois qui sont ok qui
sont très importants il y a une autre
étude qui a été réalisée par Thomas le
barbmanchan qui était publié aussi en
2020 ou 2021 qui a suivi les demandeurs
d'emploi relativement peu qualifiés lors
d'une réforme qui avait fait passer la
durée maximale d'animation pour ces
personnes peu rémunérées et qui avait
pas beaucoup travaillé donc gens
relativement peu qualifiés de 7 mois à
15 mois c'était une réforme des années
2000 et il s'est dit est-ce que c'est
passé à 15 mois ça a amélioré le salaire
et ça amélioré la qualité des emplois
retrouvés en termes par exemple de durée
du contrat et là aussi très très bonne
étude des centaines de milliers de de
d'observations etc et s'est rendu compte
que le passage de 7 mois à 15 mois
n'avait pas amélioré la qualité des
emplois réduits ça avait en revanche mis
dans le temps finalement reporter dans
le temps la sortie du chômage attention
je veux pas dire que si on donnait 6
mois à tout le monde d'un coup ça aurait
pas une détérioration de la qualité des
emplois parce que on sait très très bien
tous qu'il faut un minimum de temps pour
trouver un emploi d'accord et on sait
aussi que pour certaines personnes qui
n'ont pas de qualification ou qui ont
des freins à l'emploi qui n'ont rien à
voir avec le monétaire des problèmes de
garde des problèmes de de là on peut
faire ce qu'on veut avec l'indemnisation
ça change rien il faut leur apporter une
autre solution mi soleil étant toute
chose égale par ailleurs c'est vrai que
dès lors que l'économie va bien d'accord
on a des marges de manoeuvre entre 24
mois et 6 mois peut-être qu'il faut
certainement pas donner six mois à tout
le monde mais passer à 18 mois lorsque
l'économie va bien en comparaison
internationale comme l'avait dit ça
semble vraiment raisonnable alors
intéressante intervention effectivement
est basée sur deux études qui sont des
études complètes mais est-ce que
finalement ce c'est le son elles sont
pas un peu balayées Olivier Babeau par
notre rapport collectif au travail ah
mais ça c'est une question passionnante
et je trouve que le débat des retraites
a au moins un avantage d'une chose
malheur est bon que au moins on repose
cette question du travail alors moi je
publie un livre qui s'appelle la
tyrannie divertissement qui
contrairement à ce qu'on pense n'est pas
un appel pour qu'on travaille plus ça
n'est pas un éloge du travail ou quelque
chose qui se désole pour loisir au
contraire je me réjouis je pense c'est
moi qui soit apprenant à utiliser
une parenthèse qui avait commencé avec
le néolithique où on a perdu
collectivement enfin les gens qui n'ont
pas la chance de faire partie d'une
élite qui ne travaillait pas parce qu'il
y en a toujours eu depuis le néolithique
mais on a on referme une parenthèse on
est revenu dans des civilisations un
petit peu proche des civilisations
première n'est ce pas qui est qui sont
des civilisations du loisir ou en fait
on bosse extrêmement peu dans la vie et
dans la journée et dans quelque part je
mens je m'en réjouis je rends grâce à la
productivité les machines sont beaucoup
de choses
notre place la seule chose que je dis
c'est qu'il y a plein de façons
d'occuper notre loisir et que ces
Friedman vous savez qui avait écrit dans
les 70 ça écrit le travail en miettes où
il parlait évidemment du problème du
travail taylorien qui déshumanisé et il
montrait que à un travail déshumanisé
correspondait à loisir des humanisé
aussi un loisir que j'appelle moi de
divertissement parce qu'on n'a pas
l'énergie d'avoir un énergie de une un
loisir de construction de soi donc ce
que je dis moi c'est que on doit faire
attention parce que les inégalités
sociales aujourd'hui se construisaient à
se construisent et hier dans le travail
et à se construisent en fait aujourd'hui
dans le loisir le droit à l'appareil
tient je vous pose cette question Pablo
Vivien c'est un thème qui a été porté
par plusieurs voix à gauche notamment
ancien de la au sein de la nuque est-ce
que vous entendez cet argument dans un
contexte comme celui-là je pense qu'il
faut faire attention aux contresens le
droit à la paresse au 19e siècle c'était
pas tout à fait le même que la façon
dont aujourd'hui on l'utilise moi je
pense pour répondre à votre question et
par rapport à ce que je viens de dire
Olivier que on
aujourd'hui on met une énorme
discontinuité en fait entre le temps de
travail et les loisirs en fait ce qui ne
serait pas du travail il faut faire
attention à ça on imagine que par
exemple les retraités s'arrêtent du du
jour au lendemain de travailler ce n'est
pas le cas il s'investisse par exemple
dans des dans des associations de façon
bénévole dans les associations il y a un
tiers des bénévoles d'association qui
sont des retraités donc en fait c'est
comme une prolongation en fait de leur
travail ils gardent les enfants on en a
beaucoup parlé sur les sur les plateaux
de la même façon les gens lorsque ils le
soir il pointe et qui quittent leur
boulot ben après ils vont peut-être
garder leurs enfants ils vont faire les
coups ils vont faire à manger et tout ça
à mon avis c'est à les communistes des
années 50 et des années 40 notamment je
pense à Ambroise Croizat en fait ne
mettez pas de limite en fait à ce que
c'était que le travail c'est à dire que
pour lui on travaillait à tous les âges
la vie au bureau ou à l'usine exactement
et du coup ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
les aides sociales et ben il appelait ça
aussi un revenu du travail c'est juste
un revenu travail un peu différent et
moi je suis de ceux qui pensent que on
devrait on parle sans arrêt de réduire
le temps de travail exactement réduire
le temps de travail c'est très bien et
j'y suis tout à fait favorable mais ça
ne veut pas dire que on réduit le temps
de travail dit tripalium en fait qui ne
serait que de la douleur il faut aussi
voir ce qu'on fait en fait pendant les
32 heures ou les 28 heures sont des pour
les 28 heures par semaine ce qu'on fait
pendant ces 28 heures je pense que c'est
aussi important que de que de le réduire
merci beaucoup merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat qui était
passionnant je rappelle Olivier Babeau
le titre de votre livre la tyrannie du
divertissement qui est donc apparaître
jeudi prochain aux éditions Buchet
Chastel et ça m'offre une transition
parce que vous parlez notamment de
l'intelligence artificielle dans ce
livre c'est le thème de notre second